-Taika, it is so wonderful
to see you again.
And this is one of my
favorite books
that you're doing
these YouTube readings of.
How did you come about picking
"James and the Giant Peach
and what made you want
to start reading it with people?
-Um, well, hi.
-Hi.
-Well, I'm doing some
Roald Dahl stuff
with Netflix at the moment
and we're turning a bunch
of his books into animations
And just through my relationship
with the Dahl Story Compan
and the family and everything,
they -- it was their initiativ
just to do something
to raise some money.
And we thought it was just
a really nice idea to --
yeah, to have a series
of readings over the natural -
of a whole book, something tha
you could tune into each week.
And it just feels like a nic
thing to do with your kids
and just, you know,
for people to sit around.
Almost like a radio show
but with some
really blurry pictures.
And then it just sort of built
from there,
just getting more
and more people on board,
and it's been quite a long tim
since I've read that book.
So when I started reading it
I just kind of forgotten
it had been so long.
And so it was really like
reading it
for the first time for me.
-I'm pretty sure the only time
I have read it,
it was read to me by my mother
So I actually am a little
disappointed at how my mom
did not pull in any celebrit
friends when she read it.
-Well, you know,
this is sort of --
you know, a big lesson learned
with what we're doing,
I think,
for most parents out there
just to befriend lots
and lots of celebrities.
This is the first time
I've met most
of those people, by the way.
-You did get a pretty
impressive group.
Meryl Strip -- Meryl Streep.
[ Laughs ]
-And Meryl Strip.
We've got to get rid
of Meryl Strip.
-Well, Meryl Strip you
never want around children
She is --
[ Laughter ]
-Very different episode.
-[ Laughs ]
Camilla Parker Bowles.
How does that come about?
-I'm still very nervous
even talking about that.
I'm not even sure how
I'm supposed to address it
There were a lot of rules.
Like, okay, basically, you know,
you can't look her in the eye,
and you've got to call
her certain things.
Couldn't come in and say,
"Hey, Cami."
-Right.
-Yeah, I mean
she was really lovely.
But that was probably
the most subdued
I'd been in all the readings
-Yeah.
-I was on that.
-Congratulations.
You just received an honor
from the Queen of New Zealand.
I hope I'm stating that right.
-I'm right in with royalty
at the moment.
Me and the crown.
Yes, that's right.
I mean there's so many letters
attached to it.
I mean, O-B --
an Order of Merit.
You become an Officer
of the Order of Merit.
But it's something
I've been doing for a while.
I like to think the Queen
just googled all her subject
in the colonies and said,
"Oh, what about that one?"
What makes it good
is that it's --
you're recommended by people
in your country,
you know, for those things
And then it goes up top,
and I guess she just sort of -
yes.
-Well, that's a nice honor
Another nice honor, of course,
we spoke right before the Oscars
last time we spoke.
You were nominated for and the
you won the Oscar
for writing the screenplay
for "Jojo Rabbit."
I have to assume to some degre
because of the press
you did on our show.
I mean, that's --
-Yes, that's right.
And I think I got a lot
of points with the little card
that I made you.
-You made a beautiful drawing.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You're a handy guy.
I also want to get back
to "Jojo Rabbit,"
but you've been
making some incredible --
would you call them puppets?
What are you making?
-Yeah, I've been sewing.
I've been trying to teach
my kids how to sew.
I've been a sewer, you know,
since way back,
and they're not
really interested.
All they do is just say,
"Make me a snake.
Make me a bear."
So I just do all the work.
And it's a lovely thing.
I think, you know,
one of the things
I can take away from just
the lockdown at least
is spending a lot more tim
with the family and with my kids
and being able to try
and keep them entertained
by really exciting things
like sewing.
-Yeah.
-You know what would be
great today?
-You know, is it two girls
4 and 8?
Is that right?
-That's right, yeah.
-And they're not impressed
with your non-sewing work?
-No.
They don't --
they don't really care
for anything else I've done.
They've been on all the sets
of all my films.
I think it was just the last one
they were on,
probably like the fourth
or fifth film they've been on,
where they got an inkling
that I could make some decisions
on a film
and that I might be someone,
you know, important.
But usually -- my 8-year-old
likes to troll me
and say things like, "Oh, Dad,
I really love 'Iron Man.'
Great film."
Knowing full well
I didn't make it.
And then the 4-year-old
is at that age
where she just gets
in your head, you know.
You know, they understand
the psychology of men,
and they start to sort of
just tearing you down
psychologically.
So I'm dealing with that.
-What was your process
of writing the screenplay
for "Jojo Rabbit"
compared to other times
that you've written scripts?
Was it different?
-It was very different
in that --
and I really hope
I capture it again
where it was just quite easy
That's the first time
I've written a script
from page
one all the way through.
You know, usually I start
at the end.
Okay, this will be a good end.
And maybe something --
this is at the beginning.
Then a couple of things
in the middle,
and I try and glue them al
together and make it make sense.
But that one flowed
quite easily,
and I'm scared that
that won't happen again.
-I know you're working
on a "Star Wars" film.
You're working on another
"Thor" film.
Obviously you have to fit
into pre-existing worlds.
You obviously have
cracked it before.
I thought "Thor: Ragnarok"
was fantastic.
Is it nice to have that
structure in place of the worlds
that have been built
before you start working,
or is it a little --
-Yeah, it is.
It sort of feels --
I mean "Thor" feels
like an adaptation of something.
You know, you're using
source material.
And for me it was a lot easier
coming in, "Okay.
I don't have to make up
any characters.
This is great."
-Right.
-I just have to make them
do funny things.
I mean, who knows
with "Star Wars"
exactly what the tone will be.
But similar thing.
There's -- Well, with "Jojo" i
was also an established world.
-Yeah, that's true.
-Yeah, yeah.
But definitely on somethin
like the Marvel films,
it's a really fun
environment to work in,
because you can look
at the comic and say,
"What about this character?"
-Yeah.
-They're like, "Okay,
give it a go."
-Well it certainly paid of
last time.
They made a great choice
with you at the helm.
And it's always just a delight
to talk to you.
Stay healthy and love
to your family.
-Thanks, mate.
Lovely to see you.